The real question is like who
gets to decide what is offensive,
what is not? I'm sure you're
aware of the learn to code fiasco.
Uh Oh I her for saying learn to code
and it was really mocking this idea that
people were telling coal miners who
are losing their jobs, you know,
hey there's jobs in computer
programming and like let this out.
You should learn to code.
And so people started mocking people by
saying learn to code and then learn to
code. Apparently according
to Jack Dorsey and Vigia,
it got connected to a antisemitic remarks
and hate remarks and [inaudible] level
of Internet. This is data, that nonsense.
It's fascinating because that doesn't
mean anything like learn to code is not
offensive.
It's like,
well it's ridiculous to ask a 50 year
old man as a coal miner to learn to code
and it doesn't have a formal education.
That is ridiculous.
But I mean the fact that you get
banned for life from saying that,
that's actually even more ridiculous.
Yeah. But then there are cases where
people go and they try to create like a,
if someone, if someone who look there
are antisemites out there, right?
They do try to come up with like ways
to indicate antisemitism to each other
that other people won't detect. You
know what I mean? Via, you know, slang,
basically inner slang. Right. Um, and uh,
at some point someone needs to be able to
say, okay, wait, hold on second, this is,
we figured out this 87 x slang,
so we're not gonna allow you to say,
you know what I mean? It's
like shit, like 88 or what?
Isn't that a thing where it's like,
yeah,
doubt. Yeah, age, age.
This is though Hitler
the problem, right? This is the,
this is the exact problem that you're
talking about. Um, so, but the contrary,
the contradiction that all of
these platforms have, right,
is the early days of the Internet,
remember the early days,
it was like people were really concerned
that people would start suing websites
because of what was on the website,
right? Like, um, like the pirate bay,
the big torrent site,
you know,
like you're gonna get sued because
you've got DVD screeners on their, no,
hold on a second. We're just, this is
just where people can upload the shit.
You know, Google getting sued
because they would, you know,
direct someone in the DVDs, Koreans,
they searched for leaks, DVD screener,
you know what I mean?
And so that was a big concern in the
early days of the Internet, right?
And so we established this
precedent, they're like, no, no, no.
These sites don't have responsibility
for that right there just how people are
connecting to things. They're not
the people doing the bad shit, right?
You go up to the people doing the batch,
not the people who made it possible to
find the bad shit. Right now though,
we are in such a place where,
so all these businesses built themselves
on the idea of youtube, right?
We don't make anything at Youtube.
We just give you a place to upload your
videos, right? So at first that's fine.
All right, just take down the antisemitic,
you know, white supremacy videos, right?
Whatever. Right? But now
there's so, so many of them.
Right? And also not only that,
Youtube's algorithm is directing people
towards them and youtube is selling ads
against them and making money at them.
Right? Um, and at the same time, like,
you know, these, these videos
exist, right? Um, uh, and uh,
at the same time they're
still trying to say, well,
we have no responsibility for that
happening. It's like, hold on a second.
You guys built a system where any kind
of content is allowed and you are,
you,
you've also built the sentence and that's
directing people to that content and
you build a system that's making
money off of that content.
I think you guys have a little
bit of responsibility. Now.
I agree that the question of
who polices it or whatever,
that's an extremely
complicated conversation.
But like that's what I'm just saying
about these companies trying to have it
both ways.
They're trying to say we have no
responsibility for what's on the platform,
but also we've allowed this kind
of content to go up. You know,
I don't know if you to
profits on antisemitic videos.
I don't know. Having a test,
I talk about it in my show.
Demonetizing aspect of a youtube that
affects people whenever anything's even
remotely controversial,
controversial. They've started,
they've started doing that,
um, up until like, there's a case to talk
about in my show, um, uh, like a year,
year or two ago where they
were like running under
Armour brand under Armour ads
on like white supremacy, youtube videos,
you know what I mean? Yeah. And that,
that was like,
and their algorithm was
causing this algorithm was
causing that to happen. Right?
And these are videos getting a hundred
thousands of hits and it was like major
brands and those brands found out, oh
wow. And this is the title of these video.
Like what kind of get on with,
they say obvious antisemitic things in
these were obvious enough that anybody
would be pissed off about
him. Yeah. Um, and uh,
so that's where the demonetization thing
came from, right? Because they're like,
oh shit. Now the people who actually
pay us, the advertisers are pissed off,
right? Yeah. So, okay,
let's put a bandaid on the problem
and let's demonetize videos. Right.
Here's the problem.
Now they're doing that.
They're just doing that algorithmically,
right?
They're choosing which videos to
demonetize monetize algorithmically.
So sometimes they demonetize
stuff that they shouldn't.
That's definitely happened a ton and a
lot of shit is still getting through the
cracks. You know? And again, they're
saying, okay, we did what we did,
what we had to know.
You guys didn't solve the fucking
problem because now people are pissed off
again.
Right?
So that is the fine that these companies
are in there based on this premise of
we don't moderate, moderate
anything. But when you do that,
a lot of shit comes in and now you're
in the position where it, sorry,
it's still your house.
The Shit's happened in your house.
You went through the House party
dude, like, like the base got broken.
It's your fault.
At the end of the day,
you have to take some responsibility
for it. And like, well,
how am I supposed to police 200 kids?
I don't know.
You're the one who threw
the party. Yeah. You know,
that's a good analogy because
it's the scale that's the problem.
It's probably more like 200,000 kids in
a house. Totally. Because it's theirs.
It's unmanageable. Yeah.
When you think about it,
how many different people are on youtube
and how many different countries are
uploading videos and you
know, some of them are isis
beheading videos. Yeah. Those,
those,
like there's a bunch of cartel videos
that people have sent me to on Youtube and
they stay up for a little while.
Yeah.
You get to watch some horrible shit for
a little while before they catch on.